I'm Greg Jarrett I'm Sandra Smith I'm
Charles Payne and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Friday March 31st 2023 I'm Lisa Brady
America is an unchartered territory with
the indictment of former president
Donald Trump there are a thousand
examples of our justice system being
corrupted by politics uh this may just
be the most recent example but it is by
no means the only one I'm Chris Foster
more kids are getting a head start on
their careers in avoiding student loans
by choosing apprenticeships over College
this is attractive to people who are
concerned about outcomes right now that
tends to be folks who don't have a lot
of money to go to college and are going
to have to borrow to uh to go in and I'm
David Marcus I've got the final word on
the Fox News Rundown
foreign
[Music]
or former U.S president has ever faced
criminal charges until now Donald Trump
indicted by a New York City Grand Jury a
spokesperson for the Manhattan district
attorney Alvin Bragg confirming it last
night saying they had contacted Trump's
attorney to coordinate his surrender to
the DA's office for arraignment on an
indictment that remains under seal for
now but it's believed to center around a
hush money payment to adult film actress
Stormy Daniels during the 2016
presidential campaign made by then-trump
attorney Michael Cohen who says Trump
reimbursed him and whether that can be
elevated to covering up an unreported
campaign donation the grand jury was
also reportedly probing a payment to
former Playboy model Karen McDougall the
former president says he's 100 innocent
and has denied an affair with either
woman well it's shocking for sure and it
really is a slippery slope when we start
indicting our political opponents
particularly active candidates for
office us Florida Republican
congresswoman Kat camack thinks this
will backfire on the D.A and Democrats
instead of cleaning up the streets of
New York a George Soros back D.A is
focused on indicting a former president
and that is priority number one give me
a break Trump calls the indictment
political persecution and election
interference and an attack on our
country by Thugs and radical left
monsters Trump attorney Joe takapina
telling Fox's Sean Hannity there is no
crime I know the facts I know the law
and I really want to see where this is
going to go house Speaker Kevin McCarthy
says D.A Alvin Bragg has irreparably
damaged the country in an attempt to
interfere in the 2024 election but
Democrats are calling the indictment
long overdue and proof that no one is
above the law California congressman
Adam Schiff who led a trump impeachment
probe says the indictment is sobering
and while unprecedented is deeply and
fundamentally necessary to preserve the
rule of law so several other
investigations of trump continue
including the special Council probe
related to classified documents in the
capital Riot and in Georgia the effort
to overturn the 2020 election results
negotiations are underway on when and
how Trump would turn himself in for
arraignment in the New York City case
possibly early next week the indictment
particularly if it's what we call a
speaking indictment we'll go into lots
of detail about what they plan to prove
or think they have Trey Gowdy is a
former congressman and prosecutor that
said whether you like the defendant or
do not like the defendant we do have a
presumption of innocence and that is
more than just lip service he's also the
host of the Trey Gowdy podcast and
Sunday night in America with Trey Gowdy
and he has a new book start Stay or
Leave the art of decision making you
really
resumed innocent until such time as you
admit your guilt or a jury of your peers
concludes otherwise the indictment and
this is what juries are told in court is
not even evidence
so I mean it's a legal way a formal way
of charging someone but it's not evident
so the old prosecutor in me has seen
indictments that juries rejected and I
have seen indictments the jury's
convicted on
so let's wait and read the indictment
and then we won't have to wonder anymore
it's been reported that the justice
department
passed on bringing charges over this
does that weaken the Manhattan DA's case
and lend Credence to the argument that
he is in fact stretching a misdemeanor
into a felony
yes in the court of public opinion the
jury will never hear about that the jury
will never be told that another
prosecutorial entity with potential
jurisdiction took a pass but in the
court of public opinion and I was both a
state and a federal prosecutor but the
feds only bring cases when there is a
significant likelihood of a conviction
which is why they have a conviction rate
you know well above 90 percent uh the
conviction rate's a lot less in State
Court however let me say that there are
four that we know of ongoing
investigations into former president
Trump I
are this is the weakest actually legally
you have witness credibility issues you
have genuine statute of limitations
issues not to mention the fact that you
have to prove that this was done and
firm yourself another crime for it to be
a felony and look Federal prosecutors in
New York are among the best in the world
the fact that they took a look at this
and took a pass which should influence
the court of public opinion but the jury
in a Manhattan courtroom will never hear
about that
Trump's son Eric is calling this an
opportunistic targeting of a political
opponent in a campaign year and Trump
himself calls this election interference
can that be a winning defense for him in
this case
um
only if you consider what we call jury
nullification to be a winning defense
and that's when the jury says we're
really not interested in the law of the
facts we don't think you should have
brought this case I think the most
famous example of jury notification was
the O.J Simpson case I I really don't
know anyone who could look at those
facts and conclude that O.J Simpson did
not kill his wife uh and her friend
however the jury ignored in my judgment
the law and the facts because they
thought some higher offense had been
created so the fact that it's an
election year
ironically enough does influence whether
or not you bring charges I think the
Department of Justice has a rule that
they are not going to bring certain
charges
within a certain time period on either
side of an election because they don't
want to interfere
on the other hand Jim Comey had a pretty
famous press conference and then a later
later issued a statement uh that many
Democrats think adversely impacted
secretary Clinton in 2016.
it is never good for prosecutors to be
either in reality or perceived as trying
to interfere with elections but that's a
not a legal defense that is a defense in
the court of public opinion and it may
be a jury nullification issue will
Trump's defense lawyers say they will
vigorously fight this
um how do they do that where do they
start where should they start
uh you start with the indictment itself
you start with the statute of
limitations whether or not this case can
even legally be brought some
jurisdictions do not have statutes
limitations in fact my own home state of
South Carolina does not but many do
which means you have to bring a case
within x amount of time of when the
alleged offense took place so you defend
it there on the law first and then you
try to vigorously defend it on the facts
but judges are very loath to dismiss
indictments it has to be clearly a legal
violation to have indicted someone or
else they're going to let the trial go
forward now it may be that you don't
have the facts I've seen judges toss
indictments in the middle of a trial but
only after the prosecution has a chance
to call witnesses and again that gets to
the witness credibility issue uh Michael
Cohen went to prison for lying to
Congress uh that is not the kind of
witness that a prosecutor would want to
hinge her or his case on doesn't mean a
witness cannot tell the truth it just
means the jury's less likely to believe
that they are I don't know what all the
Manhattan D.A has I don't know what the
evidence is we probably won't know
unless and until there's a trial but to
vigorously defend something means number
one attack the indictment is either not
the you know the D.A either didn't have
jurisdiction or there's some fatal legal
flaw before you ever get to the facts
the former president of course now lives
in Florida where the Republican Governor
Ron DeSantis believed to be considering
his own run for president is criticizing
the indictment but is also saying he's
he's not going to help with any
extradition how much does that matter
procedurally
oh gosh I think procedurally not at all
I think we're in an environment right
now where you know if Governor DeSantis
doesn't have the Florida National Guard
you know outside of Mar-A-Lago some
people are going to criticizing my guess
is you know because president Trump
believes that he is legally and
factually innocent
um that he would not fight extradition
he probably uh will take the attack that
he welcomes the opportunity to quote
prove his innocence although he doesn't
have to you're Presumed Innocent you
don't have to prove it
so far legal troubles have bounced off
Trump in terms of polling will an actual
indictment be any different for his 2024
campaign and how should other Republican
candidates including his Republican
Rivals handle all of this
um I don't think it's going to impact
him at all in the primary
um I think in the old days uh maybe a
couple of decades ago the allegations
themselves would have given some people
pause I don't recall uh hearing the
phrase I don't use the phrase porn star
because I don't know what it means but
um a porn actress will go with that I
don't remember hearing that phrase much
in the past with respect to presidential
candidates but voters have already
factored in whether they think the
allegations are true or not with respect
to Stormy Daniels or Karen McDougall or
anyone else so I don't think his numbers
are going to go down at all they'll
probably go up because
people like me for instance think this
is the wrong case to start with
in terms of the general election I don't
know how many people are left undecided
in our country anymore quite frankly I
think that number is narrowing obviously
there's primary opponents handle it
um I think they should handle it by
saying his Presumed Innocent we're going
to let the process play out I doubt any
of them know the facts and I and I
guarantee you not one of them knows all
the facts so if you don't know the facts
I don't know why you would be weighing
in on it other than to say he's Presumed
Innocent let the process play itself out
and if you say anything more than that
then I think you're saying too much
is this only a weak case in your opinion
or does it also as some Republicans
argue
prove
weaponization of government and abuse of
power and politics in play in The
Manhattan DA's office
I think we've had a problem in this
realm for a while now unfortunately I
know this is wildly unpopular and I'll
probably get a lot of less than
complimentary emails but I used to tell
people this wrong to chant lock her up I
don't care how much you do not like
secretary Clinton she was never indicted
she certainly wasn't convicted by a jury
of repair she wasn't sentenced by a
judge and in this country we don't lock
people up unless all three of those
things have happened
there have been people chanting lot
Trump well before this indictment again
we don't do that in this country so the
notion that we're going to kind of
suspend due process suspend the
presumption of innocence go after our
political rivals or in some instances
the crowd doesn't even wait for an
indictment they don't even wait for the
investigation it's just this catatonic
chant lock him up or lock her up that is
a dangerous place for our country to be
we don't lock people up unless a jury of
their peers have convicted them so I
think this has been going on it's
terrible I say that as a prosecute or
not a recovering Congressman the best
hope we have left for this Republic is a
justice system that is worthy of our
respect and when you have FBI directors
um who insert themselves and do not just
one but two presidential campaigns when
you have the belief that her
investigation was kind of soft-handed
but they went after president Trump very
very hard on pretty scant facts I think
we've crossed that bridge unfortunately
and what we need is an attorney general
and District Attorneys think about what
Alvin Bragg did the day he took office
he issued a memo with all the things he
was not going to prosecute that is not
what prosecutors do they don't sit there
and second-guess a legislative body and
say look I know you say this is a crime
but I say it's not
so there are a thousand examples of our
justice system being corrupted by
politics uh this may just be the most
recent example but it is by no means the
only one Trey Gowdy thank you so much
for your time yes ma'am thank you
[Music]
this is David Marcus with your Fox News
commentary coming up
the average college tuition has more
than doubled over the last 30 years 10
000 bucks a year in state at Public
Schools 38 000 at private schools
according to the College Board the
education department says it takes
student loan borrowers 17 years on
average to pay them off some kids and
their families are saying no thanks
College enrollment is down
apprenticeships though learning on the
job are becoming more popular and not
just for trades like Carpenters
electricians and plumbers yeah it's for
a long time in this country the
apprenticeship has been in the trades
but they're expanding Douglas Belkin
covers higher education for the Wall
Street Journal he wrote an article about
students turning away from college and
toward apprenticeships for a lot of
reasons and they're moving into
Insurance banking cyber security kind of
all sorts of different places
so it typically happens is this do I
have this right you work part-time for a
company they pay for a degree or some
training along the way and then maybe
you have a leg up as far as getting a
full-time job when it's done is that
about right
that's pretty much it you take a general
study course in college the first couple
years of college or Community College
often you don't have to go do that route
then there's training within the company
and then you're working and you have a
mentor so you're learning on the job so
the idea is that you graduate your
apprenticeship in a few years and you
are you know skilled and connected and
aligned with an industry
so what kind of kids are going this
route are you finding what don't what
don't they want about a four-year
University
dead everybody's terrified of debt and
they're terrified of getting a degree uh
that costs them a lot of money that
doesn't land them a job often because
they don't have good work experience so
this is attractive to people who are
concerned about outcomes right now that
tends to be folks who don't have a lot
of money to go to college and are going
to have to borrow to uh to go in in
general and I know it's very it varies
widely from industry to industry but is
college still there's a whole a good
bang for your buck do you still make
that money back yes but
um yeah college is a good bet if you
graduate only 60 graduate if a four-year
degree in six years if you study
something that aligns with the market
maybe a third of the kids end up
studying something that they don't end
up working in so what you end up getting
is between a third and a half of kids
who graduate Who start college and
graduate and get a job leveraging their
credential the rest drop out or get a
job that doesn't demand a college degree
uh we'll talk about the kids you talked
to for the journal article and the
apprenticeships they're doing just so
people can have a couple real world
examples so the kids I interviewed for
this story are working in White Collar
apprenticeships because these are sort
of the the new curve on this
um and they were both looking closely at
colleges they both had good
um Aid offers from schools but they were
also both concerned about those things
about debt and about not having uh
experience and having a hard time
cracking the job market when they
graduated they have experiences with
siblings who are both in that situation
so they turned to these apprenticeships
um uh both in the insurance industry
that offer them you know training the
sort of odd part for them is they're
working in offices with people who are
their parents age so there's a kind of a
cultural misfit
but they sort of get over that and they
learn from them and they get mentored by
a lot of them and they learn skills that
are necessary to do the jobs that these
adults are doing in these companies yeah
and you moved through the company a bit
it's not like you're just learning how
to be an insurance adjuster or an
insurance salesperson or whatever like
you move through I.T and whatever else
that company entails right so you do
sort of stints for a couple of months in
different uh parts of the company so
that you can learn the how the business
works and then and then focus on
something that you're more interested in
that's sort of the ideal afterwards yeah
that sounds sort of like college you you
know you take a few classes and then
focus on what you're interested in
um some of these apprenticeships are
very competitive you write with the
lower acceptance rate than some Ivy
League schools yeah there's a value to
this model and that's being discovered
as these things begin to spread out so
one of the apprenticeship programs that
I connected with had 1500 applicants
this year for 100 spots so that's you
know that's that's 6.6 acceptance rate
that's that's ivy league level so what's
the application process is it similar to
college where do they even look at
grades and extracurriculars and all that
stuff or is it just how do they do it
it's more Hands-On and it struck me as
more extensive because the company is
making a significant commitment in the
kid and they want to make sure that
they're going to stick with it they're
going to have the capacity to get it
done
um so they do things they bring the
students in uh and have them work in
teams and observe them are they good
able to communicate internally or you
know with in small groups they pay
attention to things like their ability
to pay attention to detail
um they do look at grades they some of
them have written essays but they're you
know four or five steps to these
application processes and it takes it
takes a few months because they're
widowing down a lot of kids uh and they
want to make sure that they work out the
result is that the retention rates are
really high
um over 80 percent 90 and the folks that
I spoke to I guess you're right the
difference is these companies are
investing in the kids spending money on
the kid where colleges
especially not necessarily competitive
colleges they'll take any kids money
right so you know there's a big debate
in higher education should universities
have skin in the game should they
um if a student fails out graduates with
debt or doesn't graduate with debt
should the school be penalized for that
um right now the answer is pretty much
know what they do care about especially
the selective schools is
um is that they can succeed because it
reflects on their reputation and their
capacity to educate people so they want
you know they want to earn a good
reputation that isn't always
um doesn't always work that way but
that's the idea of how it's supposed to
work one of the criticisms of
traditional internship programs not
apprenticeship programs but internship
programs that are connected to getting
your college degree is that they're
mostly helpful
and useful for people for kids who have
the the financial wherewithal through
their families to um to essentially work
for free where if a kid is working their
way through college well I can't take
classes do my job and then take another
basically unpaid job
um this apprenticeship thing seems to um
negate some of that right these kids are
making good money for college kids uh
you know 30 40 000 a year with benefits
and vacation for working part-time
during the school year and full-time
during the summer so that's better than
most kids are making if they're in the
service industry or something uh so I
think this is sort of a level of respect
and also this the companies are
demanding that you're able to produce
not that they expect you to know so much
when you get in but that you're able to
work hard and focus yeah you're writing
the same article that a lot of employers
or more employers are dropping degree
requirements is that because they need a
bigger pool or because they are
realizing that degrees aren't
necessarily relevant to the job
I think it's both uh you know there's a
tremendous skills mismatched in the
country right now and there's also a
huge demand for labor so uh a lot of the
the purpose of college degrees
traditionally in the last generation has
been a signal in the noise to figure out
if a student has the perseverance to get
through a four-year program but maybe
not so much what they've learned so now
employers are beginning to look more
specifically at skills as opposed to
credentials and this fits into that mode
well you do acknowledge in this article
that there is an argument for a broader
education as opposed to what you might
what might be a narrower education that
you're getting these apprenticeships if
if the industry that you're apprenticing
in
it takes a downturn then if those are
the skills you have the argument goes
then you might have been better off
leaning on a broader education I don't
know if that's true right so the purpose
of going to college ultimately is to
learn to think critically to synthesize
information to think for yourself and to
be able to learn some schools do this a
lot of schools don't a lot of kids
graduate with um not particularly well
improved critical thinking skills but if
you do college well then you come out a
sharper clearer thinker and you are able
to learn and adapt in an economy that's
changing quickly and that's how things
should work
um apprenticeships don't preclude
learning to think critically by any
means but they do focus on a narrow set
of skills and if those skills you know
get washed away
um by technology or whatnot then you're
going to have to adapt the question is
will you be as adaptable I know some
schools colleges universities have
dropped tuitions in response to
complaints that degrees don't carry the
value that they used to are schools
responding to that complaint I mean it's
a tremendous scramble right now among
colleges to attract students there's I
think some fire sales going on at some
schools a lot of the
when you see sticker prices being
reduced a little bit of that is smoke
and mirrors because very few kids
actually pay the sticker price so some
schools will say well we're knocking our
price down from sixty thousand dollars
to thirty two thousand dollars but the
reality is the average price kids were
paying after grants was you know 32 000
nobody was paying that 60. yeah yeah
are college is going to fail what is
college even going to be you cover this
for a living what is college going to be
in five years 10 years 15 years is it
going to be like it was
whatever 75 years ago when College was
really not for meant for everybody it's
really hard to say where things are
heading in a short period of time the
there's a bunch of things that are
clearly happening right now there's an
enrollment crisis a lot of schools the
weakest schools that charge High tuition
and have low endowments are struggling
the most and they're closing begin to
close
um that's happening in the Midwest and
the Northeast where the population is
upside down you know there's not enough
kids graduating high schools schools are
working to align themselves with the
labor market and they're doing you know
this this progress being made there so
you see a lot happening in terms of
um the curriculum shifting so that kids
feel that they'll get a good job you
know some schools have placed the
guidance counselor on the center of the
Quad to sort of send a message that we
care what happens after you graduate so
you don't end up in your parents
basement so the pendulum tends to swing
depending on the how tight the labor
market is and how much you know slack
there is if and when there's a lot of
folks who are unemployed companies were
more likely to be choosier and demand
that they get these credentials before
they even apply Douglas Belkin out of
Chicago covers higher education among
other things for the Wall Street Journal
Douglas thank you thanks very much
[Music]
and now some good news with Tanya J
powers
saichi Sano is turning 90 this year and
if you're thinking he's slowing down due
to his age think again he has a history
of tackling challenges like climbing
Mount Fuji at age 80. Sano who lives in
Japan also loves to Surf and has been
recognized by Guinness World Records as
the oldest male to Surf he started his
own business earlier in life and still
runs a company that supplies Timber to
construction companies putting in a nine
to five shift these days he says surfing
is his stress reliever and catches waves
most weekends in innoshima the small
island that hosted sailing for the
recent Tokyo Olympics and was the harbor
for the 1964 games he said he was
inspired to take up the sport by an
employee at his local bank who was
always tan and didn't look like a
typical Banker the banker said his
secret was surfing so Sano followed up
and found a teacher as for what's next
Seno says he's ruled out bungee jumping
but might try rock climbing but he's not
abandoning his passion for surfing he
says he wants to try to Surf until he's
a hundred saying quote I take better
care of myself when I have goals like
this Tanya J Powers Fox News
[Music]
from the Fox News podcasts Network I'm
Janice Dean Fox News senior
meteorologist be sure to subscribe to
the Janice Dean podcast at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
listen to your podcasts and don't forget
to spread the sunshine
subscribe to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com it's time for your
Fox News commentary David Marcus
what's on your mind patriotism tolerance
religious observance and Community
involvement are all on steep declines
according to new polling published in
the Wall Street Journal and if we're
being honest the results are scary the
declining numbers in almost every area
of Civic life are not just a threat to
Civility and social cohesion they are a
threat to America's national security
the numbers strike a stark and quite
serious chord in 1998 70 of Americans
surveyed said that patriotism was very
important to them today just 38 and
that's down from 61 in just four years
there are similar dips in the numbers
for how important religion down 33 is or
Community involvement down 35 percent in
fact the only object that has surged in
importance according to this polling is
money which came to cool 12 percentage
points perhaps the most shocking and
dangerous result of the survey involves
tolerance of others and their views in
2019 80 percent of Americans backed this
foundational American value today that
has dwindled to a mere 58 percent placed
on top of each other these numbers
present a pernicious palum Pest of an
America that is changing and not for the
better we are now a nation with less
pride in our flag a nation without a God
to obey a nation in which communities
are crumbling As Americans distrust and
even hate each other
if these numbers are a cold cup of
coffee for a country that needs to wake
up to its internal divisions they are a
Christmas present to our geopolitical
foes who not only thrive on but also
Stoke this disastrous divisiveness
when special counsel Robert Mueller
dropped his report on foreign
interference in the 2016 election we
were so focused on the guilt or
innocence of then president Donald Trump
that we mostly ignored the report's main
finding that Russia's Internet troll
Farms were not so much trying to swing
an election as make Americans revile
each other while it's not entirely clear
just how much of an impact foreign
information operations not just from
Russia but also from China Iran and
others have had on these declines in
support for basic American values what
is clear is that these declines harm us
and help them
for those authoritarian Nations wishing
to depose America and the West as the
global superpower a steep decline in
patriotism is a dream come true the
American political and media class need
to take a long sobering look in the
mirror sadly these steep declines in
patriotism and tolerance The Vicious
othering of those with whom we disagree
can generate votes and clicks but at a
price far too dear for America to pay if
there is a sliver of silver around the
Cloudy disposition of the American Body
politic it may be that we are waking up
to external threats especially those
posed by China a separate Gallup poll
found that in 2018 53 percent of
Americans had a positive view of the
Communist Nation today that has cratered
to a mere and record low 15 percent
we need leaders who will stress that we
are all in this unlikely American
experiment together and that there are
powerful Global forces who want nothing
more than to destroy it was Benjamin
Franklin who wrote upon the signing of
the Declaration of Independence that we
must all hang together or most assuredly
we will all hang separately
246 years later it is still true now is
the time for patriotism now is the time
for Community involvement and now is
most assuredly the time for tolerance in
the United States of America it is never
too late I'm David Marcus author of
charade the coveted lies the crushed
donation
you've been listening to the Fox News
rundown now and now stay up to date by
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com listen ad-free on
Fox News podcasts Plus on Apple podcasts
and Prime members can listen to the show
ad free on Amazon music and for up to
the minute news go to foxnews.com
hi everybody it's Brian Kilmeade I want
you to join me weekdays at 9 A.M East as
we break down the biggest stories of the
day with some of the biggest newsmakers
and of course what do you think listen
live or get the podcast now at
briankilmateshow.com
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes